this video is sponsored by brilliant
more about them later I love my electric
bike I love it so much I wish sometimes
I could just cycle forever so I bought a
solar panel attached it to the back of
my bike and in this video I'm going to
see how far I can cycle without running
out of charge how hard can it be I'm
unable to charge my bike while I'm
cycling so here's how this is gonna work
I'm going to start with a fully charged
battery in the bike and I bought a
second battery which is going to start
empty and will be attached to the solar
panel when the first battery runs out of
charge I replace it with the second one
we find out how much charge I've managed
to get and then we repeat the process
until both batteries are completely out
of charge ah look at me young dumb full
of Hope about this experiment because
yes in this video I'm performing an
experiment and my hypothesis is that by
charging my electric bike as I cycle I
can make a 200 kilometer Journey turning
a short distance mode of Transport into
a long distance mode of Transport this
video is about that experiment and why
it it went wrong I'm setting out east
from the center of my hometown of bath
and aiming for London I'm leaving at 8
53 a.m so if I get to London if I make
it that far I should be arriving at
7pm first of all though
gotta get out of bath this is what I'm
most worried about leaving at nine on
the dots here we go
[Music]
and now I'm on the cycle Track by the
canal for the next
100 miles I'm going to be cycling
largely along the kennet and Avon Canal
path which I use every week to cycle to
my mums I wasn't keen on cycling on main
roads because of the trailer and the
small chance something could fall out of
it and damage a vehicle it could be
dangerous so the canal path it runs from
Bath to reading and then as with most
things once you reach reading things go
downhill I'll be finishing the route on
some main roads aiming for the center of
London and specifically Big Ben I should
probably mention I'm filming this on one
of the sunliest obviously because the
hottest days of the year so I'm kind of
wishing for shade but at the same time
shade is the last thing I need today now
the total plan for today is about 200
kilometers and according to my watch
one of the reasons I'm wearing these
sunglasses is to get something else
main reason
I'm an immortal struggle with Holland at
this time of year my eyes are strong
unless I'm mistake when I believe I'll
just crossed the dumbest Aqueduct
[Music]
however I think I may just take a long
time yeah I want to be on that side okay
if I'm walking though right because I
was politely asked to buy a sign
don't know how well it works yet
great publics do excellent cheese and
chips
all right
over here first Milestone reached this
is Bradford uneven
this is also the first lock of the trip
if you don't want to lock is uh
I'll explain in a little bit we're going
to see more of these it's been just over
an hour we ticked over the hour mark so
I'm just gonna start briefly take on
some water maybe have a snack all right
we've gone 16 kilometers 60 charge left
we'll definitely make 30 maybe 35
kilometers but we need to change over
solid a problem I wasn't expecting my
panel's getting Dusty I'm gonna have to
clean it off this is like the Mars
rovers is this going to be what finishes
me off dust when writing up an
experiment or scientific study you break
it up into sections first of all an
introduction in which you introduce your
hypothesis that you've already heard
background information including
assumptions that you make in your study
methodology results and discussion so
what were the assumptions that went into
my hypothesis because depending on who
you are watching this you may be
thinking yeah this is definitely going
to work or what are you doing this is
definitely not going to work let's
consider the energy going into the bike
and the energy leaving the bike my
bike's motor has a power output of 400
watts so in order to truly go forever I
would need a solar panel with 400 watts
of capacity but I don't have that I have
100 Watts however you can dial in how
much support the electric bike gives you
at any time and on the cycle I was using
no more than a 50 power so I wasn't
using 400 watts I was using 200 watts
and further my kind of electric bike
only engages its motor when I'm pedaling
and going less than 25 kilometers per
hour in my everyday usage I estimate
that I go over that threshold
about 50 of the time so in a given hour
say I draw 200 Watts half the time so
100 Watts on average this is looking a
bit better
but the panel is only going to generate
100 watts of power in direct sunlight
when it's facing the Sun and that's not
always going to be the case I need to
multiply the 100 Watts going into my
system by some number between 0 and 1 to
represent how frequently I'm facing in
the wrong direction I estimated that
this would be 50 of the time and so on
average I would be generating 50 Watts
now this may look like I'm setting
myself up for failure but firstly this
50 and this 50 are just estimates they
could be wrong secondly if it looks like
I'm drawing too much charge too quickly
then I can just reduce the amount of
support that the bike is giving me and
thirdly I don't need to finish with a
full battery if I expend a battery and
plug in a new one and find that I've
only charged it to 60 say yeah
eventually I'm going to run out of
charge but it still might be enough to
get me to London and especially when you
consider the fact that I'm gonna have to
take breaks and I'm gonna have to eat
lunch there will be times when I won't
be cycling and I'll just be able to
charge for free the numbers are
borderline but I thought there was a
chance it could work there were however
a few things I didn't expect so I did a
bit of a stop check after my refuel stop
and uh it's not looking great I
distorting a few things at the trailer
and yeah they're all gone like the route
here is
expected and not only are a couple of
tools
so too is the shock absorption included
[Music]
structural Integrity of this whole sound
let alone the charge
I may need to adjust the route this way
because I don't know how much more
longer the bike can take this the part
here is so nice
I'm not feeling too confident about this
all right
let's take a trip
I should mention by the way that I've
been using this bike for over two years
now and I love it pretty much any
Journey up to 10 or 15 kilometers in the
local area I'll use the bike for it's
definitely made me fitter and more
active and to be honest I've not had any
problems with it at all I'd still highly
recommend getting an electric bike
especially if you live in a hilly City
like bath
one hour 40 minutes in and we've gone
just shy of 23 kilometers so over 10 of
the way hey it's been challenging this
terrain like in a way that if I didn't
have the trailer would be fine but lots
of little annoying things like it keeps
triggering the parking brake because the
paths so narrow in the vegetation keeps
clipping it this is tough tougher than I
was imagining oh
[Music]
okay we are 30 kilometers in two and a
bit hours I'm limited by the terrain I'm
hoping that I I don't know man like up
ahead it looks like it's clearer but I
thought it was clearer back there I
wasn't planning on taking a rest here I
was going to take a rest when I changed
over the battery but uh I'm still
cycling for two hours um I'm going to
take on some water and some snacks and
just have a breather so whilst I'm doing
that I may as well let the battery
charge up a bit I'm not hopeful about
how much juice we've actually got so I
think it's gonna need all the help you
can get
[Music]
so I mentioned before if you don't know
what a lock is basically if you're on a
canal and you need to go up then water
doesn't flow uphill you've got to trap a
little bit of water in like a container
and then pump water from further
Upstream so that that trap bit of water
raises in level you can then open the
gates at the higher end and you can
carry on normally these locks come in
sort of ones maybe twos but uh sometimes
you've got to go up big Hills
such as
behind me this is one of the landmarks
on the route this is cane locks this is
one of the only significant bits of
uphill on the trip it's really the most
significant bit of uphill on the trip so
I was expecting the battery to die
around about now and we are on so if you
can read that 12 not sure it's going to
get me up the hill but uh what about
going I feel like the estimate's about
right I just now have no clue how much
charge is in the second battery
enough
I've never seen this many locks in one
place before this is amazing
I think that's the end of the outcome 35
kilometers this is three hours oh my God
this first batter is dead Okay so
battery is very ding tough but partially
charged not very much when it looks
okay clock in
I put the wrong battery
the second battery a little bit daint up
and Dusty and I haven't tested this yet
I genuinely don't know how much has gone
in this in the past three hours but
click
no it's going to originally say zero
oh that's not good that's really not
good I would be lying if I said I was
anything other than very disappointed in
that
I'm also surprised because that's 100
watts to face it's actually only
generating 20 watts which is uh
surprising oh that's a bad miss this was
the moment I realized something had gone
very wrong I was definitely using more
energy than I was generating now I
already mentioned one potential
explanation here dust was covering the
panel as I cycled and so I was
generating less power than expected
time for an experiment I have to change
into a lab coat because I'm doing
science what I'm doing is recording with
this camera a set of observations of how
much power the panels are generating in
optimal conditions facing the sun broad
sunlight no clouds in the sky then I'm
going to clean off the panels and we'll
see how much of a difference the dust
was making by taking another set of
observations as it turns out cleaning
the panels had very little effect before
cleaning the panels managed 48.5 watts
of power output after the cleaning they
managed
45.5 watts of power output uh I can only
assume that there was some Cloud
covering the Sun that I didn't notice or
that the water droplets on the surface
Were Somehow reducing the efficiency but
apparently by cleaning my solar panels I
actually made them worse However the
fact remains that despite being rated
for 100 watts and generating that much
before the experiments which I don't
have proof of you'll just have to
believe me the panel was only generating
what less than 50 watts in ideal
conditions I don't have an explanation
for this I wonder if maybe being jostled
around in the trailer over the really
rough ground caused something in the
panel or the battery interface to break
but whatever the cause I was generating
a lot less power than I expected
compounding this I was going a lot
slower than expected because the cycle
track was narrower and significantly
rougher than I was expecting with that
being based on how nice that same
psychopath was in the other direction
the direction I cycle in every week to
visit my mum so I was traveling below
the threshold of 25 kilometers per hour
not half the time but basically all the
time and so basically all the time I was
drawing power back to devices I could
see that things weren't working out but
I was determined to carry on going and
just see how far I could get
but when life gives you lemons uh try to
cycle to London that's how it goes right
leaving devices was interesting because
it showed that away from the cycle path
on road I was actually getting Beyond 25
kilometers per hour and so not using the
battery the extra drag from the trailer
was significant but my assumption of
using the battery about half the time on
good terrain was actually about right
however
before long second battery has just
conked out in
the middle
of nowhere
and yet somehow
the irony
right underneath a power transmission
line we are just shy of four hours in
and just shy 45 kilometers I was not
expecting the average speed to be this
slow there are several factors it is
about lunch night it is lunch time so
what I'm going to do is leave the bike
charging for the whole time I'm gonna
have lunch like half an hour or whatever
we'll see how much charge is in the
second battery we'll go from here right
I genuinely don't know how far it is to
the nearest town my notes are on my
phone maybe we'll be able to get to a
train station to get back we'll maybe so
this has been charging over lunch and
I've made an improvement to the Energy
Efficiency
click
it's going to show zero percent
18. so definitely an improvement still
18 isn't very much so I can't imagine
we're going to be going very much
further at this point it was pretty
clear that the experiment had a result
and I wasn't going to get to London my
hypothesis had been disproved disproved
because of some assumptions that went
into it being Incorrect and an
unexpected fault developing in my
equipment however the experiment being
done or not
I was still in the middle of nowhere I
had a new objective make it to the next
train station on the route without
running out of charge you know if I
wasn't carrying so much stuff and it
wasn't quite so long allergies weren't
killing me this would be rather nice
this is quite a nice experience
I didn't start my watch immediately so I
didn't have an exact number on how far
we've gone but I'll spit it out yeah
maybe about a mile
I think this experiment is going to come
to an end quite soon four percent
battery
is just about inside on my Google Maps
today just over there actually I can see
the train line that I want to get on
I've gone down to ultra low battery like
literally the minimum that the battery
can give me
it feels like
I'm dragging a sack of potatoes behind
me like that's literally how much extra
friction it feels like
three percent battery
oh
come on but I guess you could describe
as the Final Approach to the town I'm
aiming for
one percent
it is mostly downhill at the moment so
I'm just casting but
if this guy is the only hope I have is
whatever I've managed to get into the
battery in the bus like I don't know
half an hour which won't be much but it
could make all the difference I don't
know
I've got one eye on the road I've got my
other eyes looking at the battery gauge
it's been on one percent and blinking
for a little while I'm not pedaling I am
purely going downhill come on
five minutes five minutes away come on
one minute come on
five percent
oh my God I actually made it
look at that
just about to die on the lowest level
support possible
okay so this isn't London
but I've run out of charge uh I have
nothing left in the main battery
and I'm pretty sure if I checked the
other one I'd have like two percent this
is
I think where the journey has to stop
and I've just got to wait for a train it
was here as I packed everything up and
got on the air-conditioned train home I
had an epiphany I'm watching the
countryside
150 miles an hour
why didn't I just do this in the first
place
so much easier
electric bikes are fantastic I love them
but they're like dwarfs designed to be
used over short distances
in last month's video on decarbonizing
transport I talked about distance
dependency how each scale of travel
needs to be considered separately and
the fact is we have travel modes
appropriate for long distance that are
low carbon such as trains and much as I
love my electric bike there's simply no
need to make Square pegs like it fit
into round holes like Intercity travel
electric bikes will be a significant
decarbonizing influence on short
distance travel especially on Urban
Freight but asking them to do more than
that is setting itself up for failure
could you ever make this work well if
you had a working more efficient panel
then maybe but to be completely honest
by adding the solar system and and the
trailer to put it in you're adding so
much extra mass and so much extra
friction that the benefits of using the
electric bike over say a road bike
chess aren't worth it I'd like to do
this journey again on a road bike at
some point in the future as I said in
the video I actually really enjoyed the
experience it just turns out that I
basically made it as difficult for
myself as possible when you're in school
you may have found that you were taught
about subjects like solar power in a way
that also made it about as difficult as
possible for you someone stood at a
board and basically just telling you
things and expecting you to memorize
them and then regurgitate them later on
an exam not exactly effective at getting
you to understand the material and
certainly not fun a more effective
interactive easy and free way to learn
about solar power and hundreds of other
Concepts in science is this episode's
sponsor brilliant brilliant teaches you
about maths science and computer science
in a fun interactive way one of the
thousands of lessons with more added
every month is on solar power and how
much area would be required to power the
Earth's economy with solar panels if
you're a student trying to get a
different perspective to that offered in
a classroom or a busy adult who would
like to learn new topics in bite-sized
chunks little and often like I do then
brilliant can help you reach your goals
and give you a different perspective on
the natural world customizing your
learning to fit you brilliant has
sponsored my videos for several years
now and I think the reason we work so
well together is because if you like my
videos you're gonna like brilliant I try
to make videos that are about processes
and methods not just about fat and where
possible I try to implement or
demonstrate a concept rather than just
talking about it as I did in this video
so if you like this video I think you
should sign up to brilliant because I
think you'll like it too to try
everything brilliant has to offer for
free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org Simon Clark or click the
link in the description and the first
200 of you to do so will also get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription
again that's brilliant.org Simon Clark
with thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video and for being well brilliant
thank you so much for watching the video
this has been quite a long time in
production and in case you couldn't tell
it was quite deeply uncomfortable to
make so I really hope you enjoyed
special thanks must go to my executive
producer patrons whose name is on the
screen right now if you would like to
support my work choose a video topic for
me to cover a month and get access to
exclusive behind the scenes Vlogs then
please do consider signing up to my
patreon link down there in the
description if you enjoyed the video
please do pop it a like and do share it
with people that you think may find this
experiment interesting also let me know
what you thought down there in the
comments that just leads me to say thank
you again for watching I'll see you in
the next one